a good lamp is going to be challenged
for right-hander matt manning making the
16th start he's coming off a good one a
w is last time out against milwaukee on
wednesday
robert strikes out first one for manning
tonight carlos rodin goes to the mound
for his 23rd start of the year his era
238 looking for his 13th win it's been a
remarkable year in a lot of different
categories
swinging a miss strike three first
strikeout for rodong
called strike three bottom of the zone
grossman rejected
and ball four first base runner of the
ball game is yasmani grandall to lead
off the second inning
now that was traverse city ball four
the one one
hot shot nice play by jonathan skope
good range and an accurate throw to get
hernandez
struck him out fastball challenged him
and carlos rodon gives him a little
smile on the way out these guys know
each other very well so something's
working for him
go back to the heater and see you later
four strikeouts for rodon
lefty to righty rodonda cameron high for
ball four
3-2 another strikeout 92-94-96
3-2 it's ball four it's the third walk
for manning
into center field ta's got a base hit
and goodwin's on his way to third throw
goes into second and now the sox are
turning up the volume on the offense
here with two on and nobody out luis
robert
gets hit
monkatta for one he bats with the bases
full and nobody out they're going to
play for a double play chance
second base
scope and castro and the pass to first
not in time so juwan gets an rbi tigers
only pick up one out and the sox have a
one nothing lead
first and third one out here's grand all
yeah it's on o2 with a seed to center
field reyes is there t.a tags it's a sac
fly for grandahl
and it's two nothing socks runner at
first moncada with two down in the
batter of lloyd jimenez
that ball is hit very well by eloy and a
right center field and it is off the
wall on a hop
monkada's around third he scores eloy
jimenez labels a baseball and it's three
nothing
now the payoff to paradis and he draws a
walk that's a good at bat right there it
is second walk issued by carlos rodara
here's the 1-1
jammed him but that's going to drop
center field willy castro has the tigers
first hit of the night
here's victor reyes
strikeout victim in the first
another row two back up the box get
through and it gets under the glove of a
dicing cesar hernandez
paredes scores and the tigers are on the
board thanks to the rbi single that
bleeds through the infield from victor
reyes
here's jonathan scope flew out to center
his first timeout the payoff to scope
back up the middle and off the glove of
rodon
hernandez tries to tag him they did not
tag him he tagged him with the glove but
not the ball
reyes is safe for the run scores
heads up play by victor reyes
he outfoxed cesar hernandez
one run away and a chance for this man
miguel cabrera
fly ball center field robert is in
reyes will test him here comes the throw
not going to get there in time and we
are tied thanks to the sacrifice fly
from miguel cabrera we got ourselves a
tie ball game that's his
1800th career rbi miguel cabrera as jose
ruiz comes on for the 56th time
paradis hits one sky-high on the infield
third base side
it'll be moncotta to glove it nice work
jose ruiz
3-2
line to left again this will go rolling
and rolling and rolling
and it's extra bases one more time for
yasmani grandau who is right now the
toughest out in major league baseball
popped it up right side jonathan scopes
got it and matt manning does a nice job
get over off the glove of sheets and
into center field look at this going to
dig for it look at this and he's going
to get there standing up
set and the pitch swing and a miss
strike three
excellent curve ball to get him
pitching change to ian kroll here in the
six
another 1-2 and he gets garcia starring
the old backdoor breaking ball
then he struck him out back to back
strikeouts looking
big man and a switch hitter
third base that's a fair ball monkatta
snaps off a one hopper and nailed him oh
an exceptional play by johann monkana
we've been talking about yuan's defense
most of this season because it's getting
spectacular
swing and a miss on a fastball right
down the middle and burr blows him away
for the first hour
two down here's another one
hey strikes out hitmanage three
strikeouts for drew hutchison so far
these look good
greg kimbrell comes into the game he's
on for the 59th time
payoff again from kimbrell
he struck him out reach back for the
fastball two gone
hit him he'll take it
there goes grossman it gets all the way
to the backstop
runner at second two out harold castro
tigers one for five tonight with runners
in scoring position
ground ball wide of first and it goes
through into right field here comes
grossman he will score and harold castro
comes through
with a two-out rbi single and the tigers
have their first lead of the night alex
lang will work the bottom third of the
chicago order
the 1-0
slap to first scope will do it again two
away
the one-two
ground ball to second
tigers win the series opener alex lang
with his first major league save
4-3 the final good one in detroit
[Applause]